[Applauso]
[Musica]
buonasera dunque i ragazzi del tenni
quando mi hanno chiamato
e mi hanno dato solo una regola quella
di non leggere niente soprattutto la
biografia e quindi io me la lego
allora
un po lunga e sono nati in un ospedale
non profit
ho fatto le scuole elementari e medie e
presso una scuola non statale non profit
un fatto ginnastica ne ho fatto parte di
una squadra di ciclismo la forti e
liberi che era un'organizzazione non
profit
ho ricevuto una borsa di studio da una
fondazione privata uno che se non provi
per sperimentare una università
americana new york university
il mio primo lavoro è stata la conf
commercio di bologna che è
un'organizzazione no profit
miei fondi pensione sono gestiti da una
mutua privata non profit
ho fondato impegno molto del mio tempo
nell'associazione festival del
fundraising che è un'associazione non
profit e due dei miei figli vanno ad una
università non statali a milano una non
profit
la terza ha imparato a suonare uno
strumento musicale presso una scuola di
musica non profit
dono alle organizzazioni non profit
stasera sono qui al ted che è una non
profit
e la casa di riposo dove i miei figli mi
potrebbero mettere da vecchio è
un'organizzazione non profit ma
soprattutto la mia tomba sarà
all'interno di un camposanto gestito da
un'organizzazione non troppo tutti voi
tutti noi
tutte le persone che sono qui presenti
io non sono speciale in questo siamo
attraversati dalle organizzazioni non
profit non ce ne rendiamo nemmeno conto
di quanto abbiano a che fare con la
nostra vita
le organizzazioni non profit
per fare tutto questo in un qualche modo
bisogna rendersi conto che ci vogliono
dei soldi
ci volevano dei soldi ci vogliono tanti
perché
sostanzialmente quando noi pensiamo al
dono
pensiamo di avere chissà fatto quale
cose in realtà se facciamo due conti
e paragoniamo i semi lee hall di di
donazioni con i 1.800 miliardi di
prodotto interno lordo cioè
semplifichiamo sopra acquisti sotto doni
noi potremmo dire che sostanzialmente se
andassimo in un supermercato e avessi
uno scaffale di 100 metri
dedicato alla donazione ci sarebbero 30
cm
in america ci sono tre metri rispetto ai
100 metri più o meno è comunque una
percentuale molto molto molto piccolo
doniamo poco e poi torniamo anche male
andiamo male perché pensiamo al mondo no
profit come a uno spazio di gentilezza
di educazione di volontariato di spazio
in cui uno tutto sommato fa quando
è residuale
ma non pensiamo al mondo non profit come
qualcosa che possa cambiare
profondamente la società quello e
delegato ai politici al governo
noi paghiamo le tasse
noi votiamo
tutto sommato il nostro dovere l'abbiamo
fatto mentre chi deve cambiare veramente
sono altri
il mondo non profit può cambiare può
cambiare se cresce
se diventa più importante
allora questa sera dico
proviamo a immaginare cinque consigli
cinque piccoli brevi semplice per
pensare a donare in un modo diverso
a donare in un modo un po più
intelligente un modo che abbia più
effetto sul cambiamento che in un
qualche modo
generi più cambiamento
55 cose molto brevi
la prima è
noi facciamo
mettiamo il mondo non profit in un
grande secchio per cui va beh sappiamo
cosa vuol dire fame cosa vuol dire
cancro cosa vuol dire tumore al seno
cosa vuol dire malattie renali cosa vuol
dire disabilità cosa vuol dire più o
meno ce l'abbiamo un'idea di questo
però non abbiamo un'idea
se un organizzazione si occupa di un
problema cronico o di gestire
un'emergenza che un conto e curare un
tumore al seno che è importante
un conto è spendere soldi perché questo
non avvenga
un conto è occuparsi del
trapianto divenne di un bambino
un conto è occuparsi delle malattie
renali o della fame a lungo periodo o
delle emergenze e delle improvvise
carestie sono due cose diverse
ma tutte bene che sia chiaro il mio non
è un giudizio
morale
prossimo vogliamo cambiare forse
dobbiamo iniziare a pensare che la
soluzione ai problemi cronici sia quello
su cui noi dobbiamo dare attenzione e
quindi magari scegliere con cura le
nostre donazioni e pensare alle
organizzazioni che hanno una causa
magari meno emotiva meno appealing si
direbbe d'inglese meno eccitante
però che costruisce di più nel lungo
periodo
secondo punto
a tutti noi viene in mente una grande
frase è la domanda che ci facciamo
se io mi potessi chiedere
sostanzialmente qual è
il
la domanda che vi fate prima di donare
è questa
vi assicuro che noi abbiamo fatto
un'indagine più di una volta in un
qualche modo la risposta è stata
questa la maggior parte delle persone
quando prima di fare una donazione si fa
questa domanda che percentuale dei
programmi percentuali della mia
donazione va ai programmi che
percentuale va ai costi generali con
orsoni i costi generali sono stipendi se
di marketing spesa per la raccolta fondi
cioè spesa per raccogliere più soldi
cioè tutte quelle quei costi virgolette
improduttivi che nella vulgata comune
sono visti come uno spreco una
malagestione
lavori nel non profit non vorrai mica
anche essere pagato
questo è un po l'idea che ci siamo fatti
e finché noi non sosteniamo le strutture
delle organizzazioni non profit non
possono crescere e se non possono
crescere non possono cambiare la realtà
questa è una domanda che dà ai donatori
cattive informazioni vi faccio questa è
la classica domanda che è la classica
situazione che si vede in un sito web no
si vede un euro e siamo tutti contenti
perché soltanto il 16 per cento delle
spese generali sono quelle spese per
mandare avanti la struttura in realtà
più a bassi gli stipendi meno fai market
in meno fai raccolta fondi meno usi
persone meno stai a spendere sulla
struttura meno la l'organizzazione
crescere
in un qualche modo un piccolo esempio va
da pensare a questo due mense che si
occupano di servizi caritatevole ben sa
comunica di avere il 10 per cento di
costi generali la mensa b il 30 per
cento se io facessi alzare la mano
questa sera l'ottanta per cento dei voi
senza sapere niente
nessun'altra informazione
darebbe la sua donazione alla mensa
senza dubbio
peccato che potrebbe succedere che la
mensa non funziona la messa di funziona
il tema è il risultato che produci non
quanto costi
ed è incredibile perché se ci pensate
noi facciamo questo tipo di calcolo
esclusivamente sul non profit
perché se io andassi a casa da un mio
amico e gli dice si guarda sai che sono
andati in un negozio di scarpe
ho comprato negozio di scrivere un paio
di scarpe erano cioè bruttissime no però
avevano dei costi generali bassissimi
cioè una roba piena di buchi e non mi
piacevano però chiesto alla commessa
quanto guadagnava il commesso non regala
pochissimo l'affetto bassissimo il
telefono non l'avevano è una cosa
fantastica ho scelto quelle scarpe
se voi ci guardate il costo di progetto
su una scarpa di 100 euro
il programma e 21 euro il 21 per cento
ma nessuno si lamenta di questo
terzo piccolo consiglio
c'è un gran fiorire di persone che fanno
raccolta fondi
contro le organizzazioni non profit
nulla di sbagliato
nulla di scorretto
però in un qualche modo
ci sono casi particolari
va bene aiutare qualunque tipo di
situazione però forse non è meglio
intervenire sulle radici di questo
problema
questo è un caso di genere
perché non aiutare le organizzazioni che
se ne occupano e che vogliono risolvere
il problema alla radice piuttosto che
aiutavano a singola realtà massimo
rispetto per i coniugi ferraris che in
quattro giorni hanno raccolto 4 milioni
di euro la più grande raccolta fondi
crowdfunding fatta in italia
ma è questo di cui abbiamo bisogno
o forse di un'organizzazione non profit
solida che possa interagire nella
società in un modo pieno e più completo
piuttosto che
singole raccolte personali che vanno
bene non sto parlando né male
in qualche modo sono più rischiose e
ricordatevi che quando parliamo di crowd
funding
parliamo di 105 milioni di raccolta
fondi all'anno contro i 6 miliardi del
fundraising fatto dalle organizzazioni è
abbastanza facile raccogliere super
funding ok come un busker un artista di
strada che suona in piazza ai 15 20 30
50 persone fai presto raccogliere un po
di soldi mai potremo mettere in piedi
l'orchestra e far suonare la quinta di
beethoven quelle più complicate
quarto piccolo consiglio qual è la
vostra causa
mio padre è morto di leucemia la mia
causa e quella mio fratello è mio zio è
ho visto i miei bambini crescere in
l'ambiente la disabilità la solitudine
qualunque qual è la vostra causa
qual è la causa che mi rappresenta
sheila con cura io dico sempre quando
uno deve fare una donazione per
scegliere un appartamento che devi
comprare quanto tempo ci metti agenti
immobiliari
internet e così via c'è scelgo qualcosa
che mi rappresenti guardo le spese
condominiali e spese generali guardo
alla efficienza energetica l'efficienza
dell'organizzazione guarda tutto pallo
con coloro che abitano vicino cioè in un
qualche modo faccio una scelta con cura
rispetto a quello che io sono
una volta che ho fatto la scelta con
cura
quinto e ultimo consiglio il mio
consiglio è di rimanere lì
tutta la vita
di essere dentro quella causa con le
nostre piccole o grandi donazioni 10
euro e 20 euro 1000 1 milione per tutta
la vita dentro rimanerci fedeli per due
motivi il primo è lever gela potenza
economica che voi potete mettere in
campo in una vita a molto più effetto
per l'organizzazione non profit ma la
seconda cosa che nel
appassionarmi all'organizzazione non
profit nel donare poi donare poi donare
poi donare divento io stesso
l'evangelista di quella causa di vento
io stesso qualcuno che propone diventa
un fund raiser a tutti gli effetti della
raccolta fondi e quindi in un qualche
modo la mia persona diventa un soggetto
che produce cambiamento
nell'organizzazione non profit
quindi il mio consiglio e rimanete
fedeli le ali alla organizzazione non
profit che scegliete e non salta back
herat e farah una causa e l'altra 10
euro qui a 2 euro
[Musica]
una e una sola con forza con costanza
siamo al chilometro zero
siamo in romagna c'è una bellissima
frase di pier paolo pasolini che mi ha
sempre colpito e che diceva romagnoli
sono come gli italiani ma all'eccesso è
vero e o meglio li dividono di più
scherzano di più sono un po più
malinconici a volte sono un po più
tristi sono più felici sono estremamente
felice a volte sono un po all'eccesso
il mio invito e quando pensate
all'organizzazione non profit di pensare
che potete realmente cambiare la società
con un po di accesso
[Applauso]